hi guys today I'm going to talk about
something that I think you will find
pretty interesting and it's about when
to start speaking a foreign language
this is one of the most common questions
that I get asked asked that I get asked
out there and I think it's a it's it's a
good one at that so let's talk about
when to speak there are normally two
schools of thought that are at the
extreme size of the spectrum and then
there's a lot of positions in between
according to the first school of thought
you should speak from the very beginning
now let's analyze pros and cons the pros
are that the sooner you do something the
better you become at it for example this
goes for speaking or other skills like
swimming walking running you name it
on the other hand though the cons are
the detractors of this school of thought
say that the moment you speak without
knowing much you don't have words to
express yourself you don't understand
and then you have all sorts of
psychological bears especially for
adults were normally scared of speaking
the experience can be traumatic if you
stumble upon someone was not who's not
very helpful
and and so on and so forth according to
the other school of thought which says
that you should get a lot of input
before before speaking before making any
attempt at speaking the pros are
undoubtedly that you have a lot of
inputs so we have a lot of words and you
have been listening to language for a
long time so you will surely have a
better listening comprehension of those
who have not Donald that but the cons
are that if you start doing that if you
start exposing yourself to a lot of
content which is fantastic then the
moment of speaking might not be that
easy in the sense that you keep telling
yourself I have to listen to some more
stuff before I speak etc etc and even
when that happens you will figure out
that there's a big gap between your
speaking skills and your listening
skills what do I think about this well I
think that you should do whatever you
want meaning there is no best method
there is no ideal situation it depends
on a number of things let me break it
down into two main factors the objective
factor is the language distance that is
the distance between the language
your mother tongue in the language
you're trying to learn for example if
I'm an Italian and I wanna learn Spanish
Spanish is a relatively close language
to Italian so it might be actually a
good idea to start speaking from the
very beginning because the structures
are really similar and I don't have to
make that many efforts in order to
express myself on the other hand in
languages which are really really
distant especially in terms of syntax
because syntax that is the way we form
sentences really plays a big role in the
way we express ourselves and the amount
of mental energy that we have to put
well in that case you might wait a
little bit before before speaking so
this is the objective factor language
distance on the other hand the
subjective factor depends on the
individual that is depends on you
meaning that you know the choice of
speaking depends on a number of things
that depend on your language experience
on those languages you already speak on
your mind set if you're an experienced
language partner who had a lot of
experience speaking with people from the
very beginning or even after a little
bit well you can decide and ponder and
and and decide the the best thing for
you whatever whatever you decide when
you start when you start speaking with
someone and make sure a fact is its
final tip make sure that you find
someone who is helpful and who is
willing to help you this is really
important because if you find someone
who's not really known to help you or
he's he's a little bit difficult or or
whatever that's not that's not gonna be
very good so that goes without saying
you know communication joyful
communication and feedback can do
wonders to your language for your
language skills in particular speaking
skills two more things before I go what
kind of learner are you I'm wondering
what happened in your life and he's not
the whole story but just let me know
when it comes to speaking your
experience if you had traumatic
experiences or spoken you normally speak
from the very beginning or you wait a
little bit and really eager to hear what
do you have to say and if you do that on
the block that's even better you can
obviously bro write comments here on
YouTube because Kevin and I my friend
Kevin
your house and I wrote I think an
awesome article about this and it would
be great if you drop by if you swing by
and drop a couple of comments you can
see it the article by clicking on the
link in the description box thank you
very much for listening to me and have a
fantastic day bye bye
you